I can bring you an alarm
or I can bring you in cold
[Music] razor crusts am i right pre Empire how
much are they paying you is it true that you
guys never take off your helmets I think I have
to use the vac tube do display this is a trophy
give a pet give a sweet tooth do you believe in
the power of a curse if you have your hearing
tested like they're planning a trip soon can
you remember the tallest man you've ever seen
please lower your plaster something lower theirs
first we have you for dove one I like those odds
double kill over a kill kill takun killing
spree killed prosody Kilimanjaro kill
test repeat killed apocalypse
kill Ian Ayre killing frenzy
betrayal
[Music] hey spit that out
[Music] [Applause]
[Music]
but it's a lucky thing I had my pieces
your pieces my gun oh all right wait I
started blasting back then they ran away
I ran after him okay bang try to shoot
him in the back but I don't want so good
either Negro that's all you had to say
[Music]
mm damn Jimmy there's some serious gourmet
[__] [Music] you can't generalize I'll
find us some lodging and I'll come back for
you you stay right here you stay don't move
no no I don't think I will great maybe I'll try
some of that knife Tony was telling me to get
I want the he'll come on all right would you
like some food hey here's the plan I am going
to look after you until the mandalorian gets
back and then I'm gonna charge him extra for
watching you you see where that shot came from
yeah came from that Ridge we're gonna wait until
dark well what if she escapes she's got the high
ground she'll wait for us to make the first move
[Music] [Applause] [Music]
tiny you can live free of worry I'm already
free of worry and I'm not in the mood to
play soldier anymore especially fighting
some local warlord he's Imperial I mean
[Music] we're on the verge of
greatness we were this close
[Music]
no living thing has seen you without my helmet
since I swore Creed I am
NOT a living thing [Music]
listen you're not going anywhere we need
you let's just come up with his telling me
the child will be safe in your care if
you do so I can default to my secondary
command but you'll be destroyed
and you will live my time has come
you must continue your journey
without me what what what are you
[Applause]